بهذا الموضوع لكن من وجهه نظر الصحافه
العالميه التي اولد اهتماما كبيرا
بالزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وقد
تناولته من جوانب عده بعض ماوردته الصحف
نتابعه في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
رات ان نسبه هائله من ضحايا الزلزال هم من
الاطفال واليافعين ووصفت الظروف المؤلمه
التي جرى فيها انقاذ بعضهم بينما لم يحالف
الحظ اخرين الصحيفه نقلت عن منظمه الامم
المتحده للطفوله يونيسف انها لا تتوفر على
ارقام واضحه حتى الان لعدد الضحايا من
الاطفال لكنها شددت على انه يصعب ايجاد
طفل لم يتاثر بهذه الكارثه خصوصا في
المناطق السوريه
عمليات الاغاثه لا تسير كلها على ما يرام
مجله الايكونوميس كتبت عن جماعه الدفاع
المدني المسماه الخوض البيضاء وقالت انها
تكابد مصاعب جم في العمل بمناطق شماليه
سوريا من اسباب معانات هذه المجموعه انها
محدوده العدد مع وجود ثلاثه الاف متطوع في
منطقه يزيد عدد سكانها عن اربعه ملايين
شخص كما ان مستشفيات المنطقه ومناها
التحتيه الصحيه تعرضت في اوقات سابقه لقصف
روسيا والنظام السوري ما جعلها تفتقد للحد
الادنى لمواجهه الكارثه الحاليه سارد دوش
كتبت في واشنطن بوست ايضا عن معاناه
المسعفين والمهم من هول المواقف التي
يتعاملون معها الكاتبه تحدثت الى مسعفين
شرحوا معاناتهم وعجزهم في كثير من الحالات
عن انقاذ الناس بسبب صعوبه الظروف وحجم
الدمار ناهيكا عن قله الامكانات الماديه
واتفق المسعفون على ان المنطقه تعيش ظرفا
كارثيا غير مسبوق وان المساعدات لا ترقى
الى حجم الكارثه حتى الان مجله لبنان
الفرنسيه رات ان الحاجه باتت ملحه في
المناطق المنكوبه في كل من سوريا وتركيا
لاستعمال تكنولوجيا الفضاء لرصد المتضررين
ومواقعهم وتوجيه فرق الاضافه نحوهم وقالت
المجله ان حجم الكارثه واتساع نطاقها
وصعوبه
عوامل تفرض الاستعانه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه
التي سيتضح كم هي قيمه وحتميه لكنها اردفت
ان الامر يخضع لاجراءات ينظمها ما يسمى
الميثاق الدولي للفضاء والكوارث الكبرى
وهي اتفاقيه لا يمكن تفعيلها بسهوله خصوصا
في مناطق الحروب والنزاعات
نقرا ان سوريا لا تستفيد فعليا من
المساعدات الخارجيه لاسباب عده منها ان
الكارثه تدمرت الطريق المؤدي الى المعبر
الحدودي الوحيد ومن الاسباب الاخرى وفق
الصحيفه الحدود المغلقه مع تركيا والعزله
السياسيه التي تعانيها سوريا وما سمتها
الصحيفه سياسه التجويع التي يمارسها
النظام على المناطق الخارجه عن سيطرته
فبينما تعج الطرقات على الجانب التركي من
الحدود بالمركبات واليات الانقاذ بدت
المناطق المتضرره في الجانب السوري اقرب
الى الحدود